but I just have one last credit card I
just can't quite seem to uh get rid of I
don't have a balance but I'm just trying
to convince myself to actually get rid
of it I love this and Kelly I'm I break
this down in the new book into eight
different characters so can you tell me
which one you fall into is it out of
fear is it for the rewards is it the
convenience what is causing you to go I
I can't cut this thing up pressure of
like everyone said like you should
always have one you're because you never
know if you're going to get stuck in a
situation where you're going to need
that okay so for you I'm going to call
you the emergency shelter that's the
sixth personality in the book I need my
credit card in case of emergencies right
probably yeah okay well let me tell you
there's a way better emergency fund and
it's where you become the bank instead
of Capital One and that's called an
emergency fund do you have $1,000 save
for baby step one I do I'm actually in a
four and six wonderful so how much money
do you have in savings almost 11,000
amazing now tell me when was the last
time you had an $1,000 emergency uh
never